welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
in this episode i spoke with dr
terry walls dr walls is an md
and a clinical professor at the
university of iowa she specializes in
clinical research
testing the impact of diet and lifestyle
on multiple sclerosis
she has an unbelievably remarkable story
about recovering from
secondary progressive ms she was bound
to a reclined wheelchair
by changing the food she eats her diet
has helped hundreds of thousands of
people with autoimmune
health conditions we differ in opinion
in a few ways
her diet wouldn't have worked for me
however it clearly works for a ton of
people
i still strongly believe i'm missing a
gut healing component
that would enable me to vary my diet
more but i still bring awareness to the
lion diet because
it works for people especially those who
have absolutely no other option
if you can get away with the walls
protocol instead successfully
then you'll be able to eat more foods
she's a very smart lady
this episode is brought to you by true
local t-r-u-local.ca
where i get my meat you choose what goes
in your box and they send it to you
flash frozen
it's super high quality they connect
with local farmers and then you get to
buy farmed meat
sustainable nutritious delicious their
grain-fed beef's great
wild salmon and their lamb which is what
i mostly eat
is bom code mp for free steaks in your
box
mark the ceo has been one of my best
supporters strongest supporter of the
podcast
and was sending me meat boxes when i was
having a hard time affording it
i no longer am because of you guys
supporting me honestly and humans like
mark from
local so that's very nice trulocal.ca
code mp for free steaks with your box
i'd also like to introduce you guys to
one of my favorite snacks it's a new
favorite snack
brooklyn biltong you can go to
brooklynbiltong.com
one of the easiest ways to get healthy
is to replace the crap you're eating
with healthy food that's still kind of
snacky i went cold turkey into pure
health food
no packaged foods no fun i didn't know
how to cook
and that was because there weren't any
packaged foods that were healthy enough
that i could comfortably eat
and now there are brooklyn biltong
find them at brooklynbiltong.com is a
small company that makes
biltong which is a south african dried
meat dish
and their options are either spiced or
made with just
salt and apple cider vinegar that's
their naked version this one the one i
eat
and beef just air dried beef it's kind
of like jerky but
it's built on code mp for 15
off highly highly recommended especially
if you're snacking on chips all the time
seriously consider switching to
something like this
it's a health food packaged up like
something that's unhealthy
that's brooklynbiltong.com and use
codemp for 15
off i'm so glad i can advertise products
i use rather than
fit tea or some sort of smoothie i
really like the products and the people
i advertise for
and that makes me happy i hope you enjoy
this episode and you learn something
[Music]
dr terry walls welcome to my podcast
oh thank you for having me i'm really
excited to talk to you
uh i'm very familiar with your work but
if we could start off by you giving a
brief background
about who you are and what it is that
you do for my audience
so i'm a clinical professor of medicine
here at the university of iowa
i do clinical research testing the uh
impact of diet and lifestyle to treat
multiple sclerosis
related symptoms uh and actually we're
doing really groundbreaking research
now the reason i am doing all this is my
own personal
recovery story from a really quite
severe disability due to secondary
progressive ms
four years at silver cline wheelchair
despite seeing the best people taking
the newest drugs
uh and going steadily downhill
it's the point we had four years in the
to recline wheelchair unable to set up
but using diet electrical stimulation
uh lifestyle i reversed all of that
uh and one year later you know i'm out
of the wheelchair walking around
pain-free for the first time in 27 years
and i was able to complete an 18.5 mile
bike ride
so this really changed how i thought
about disease and health it changed the
way i practiced medicine
and it would change the type of research
that i do
how long uh how old were you when you
started exhibiting ms symptoms
you know in retrospect symptoms began
during medical school
so that would have been probably about
25. i now i wouldn't get diagnosed for
another 20 years
uh when i started having problems
walking
uh in that i was 45 at diagnosis
yeah okay and then what was your diet
like
prior to the diet you're doing now so
i had been following a low-fat
vegetarian diet so lots of beans
lots of legumes whole grains so
certainly uh we would have thought that
to be a
ideal diet but for me apparently how
my interpretation of a vegetarian diet
turned out to be
not helpful and i would eventually learn
that i have
severe uh food intolerance to gluten
uh grain uh to dairy and to eggs
have you found that this is eggs across
the board or is it specifically chicken
eggs
uh for me it's uh eggs across the board
well uh
caviar is fine i would tolerate caviar
and caviar is
probably a super food i think it's
incredibly good for you
i don't have a problem with that but uh
you know eggs across the board are a
problem
dairy across the board uh is also a
problem for me
okay um a brief background about what i
found i had
very very severe autoimmune arthritis
and
i actually managed to get it under
control with a diet i i'd heard of
you before i'd been visiting naturopaths
but i'd never had someone say
hey try the walls protocol right they'd
say go gluten-free it would never make
much of a difference
uh and i ended up on a diet that was
very similar to your protocol so
i was eating a lot of meat and greens
basically and my symptoms yeah my
symptoms resolved
very quickly and then when i got
pregnant my symptoms worsened and
i couldn't get better after that um so
what i'm doing now
is a carnivorous diet so i'm i'm
literally just eating meat
um my major intolerances were
in order of severity gluten containing
grains
dairy um legumes like soy
in particular yeah so you'd need a low
lectin diet
yeah i've certainly found that people
who
have a autoimmune involving their
joints uh appear to be much more
sensitive to lectins
keep in mind that there are also lectins
in meat so
even a carnivorous diet still has
lectins in it uh so it's it's not
completely
zero lectins but it's a lower lectin
some folks may need an even more
restrictive diet that is
a sort of a pre-digested diet it's
something that's been used for
inflammatory bowel disease and that
would be you know something i would use
for the most extreme
uh cases okay and what does that look
like
uh it's really quite challenging uh
that's going to be
a elemental uh uh
formula diet so you're not eating food
you're on the elemental formulas which
by the way have a pretty difficult taste
for most people
and we would use that for three to six
months
and typically during that six month
period your immune cells
reset the memory cells are gone
and we can begin to very slowly
gradually reintroduce
food again yeah interesting i've spoken
with a number of doctors
that use something so use either an
elemental diet or they use
a stewed grass-fed meat um
and they do that for a period of time i
talked to the person who
who did gaps um yeah that's how she
starts off
um so i i think that that could also
work uh
as uh i've heard a reference to a
restorer diet
um you know lots of uh broths
a lot of collagen
uh you know boiling chicken feet boiling
hooves uh to extract more of that
collagen
in gelatin it can be very very healing
for
the small intestines you know and part
of the other
uh difficulty is if we don't have
appropriate digestion in the gut
to breaking down these proteins that is
the big problem
uh so when we're when we're reacting to
proteins
so in my case and also in your case uh
on a pathologic basis there are several
things are going on
one is that the small intestine
you know should have tight junctions
to keep all the food inside while it's
being digested by the
enzymes that break down carbohydrates
and break down proteins
so you're down to sugars and amino acids
when you're down to sugars and amino
acids they diffuse in the bloodstream
there are small molecules my immune
cells
recognize that as food and that's not a
problem
if i have a leaky gut so that the
there's gaps the the
divisions between the cell walls have
opened up and now
bacterial fragments get into my
bloodstream
and food proteins that have not been
completely digested
get into my bloodstream where my immune
cells
will correctly recognize that that is
too big to be food
and it has the amino acid sequence
that's similar to
pathogens so that's called
pathogen associated molecular patterns
my immune cells immediately react
now on top of that the immune cells
may have an amino acid sequence that's
similar
in your case to structures in your
joints in my case
structures in my brain and so my immune
cells react
to the food and there's a cross-reaction
to my brain
which you know caused me pain and
suffering for 27 years and for you you
know the pain and suffering uh to your
joints
so i explained to folks that we there's
several things that we need to do we
want to
heal that leaky gut so we don't have the
leakage of incompletely digested
food particles into the bloodstream we
want to help
the digestive process along
so all those proteins are broken down to
amino acids
and then get into the bloodstream and
then the other things
we want to do is get rid of those
factors
that makes for the leakiness in the gut
so it might be alcohol
it might be non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory agents
it may be the yeast overgrowth of all
the sugar and carbs that we're eating
it may be other medications that people
are on
i so there are several factors that i'm
uh addressing
uh in all of this uh but you know the
addition of
uh digestive enzymes to help the
digestion can be very very helpful
okay that's interesting uh i wanted to
delve a little bit into digestive
enzymes and your thoughts on probiotics
but starting with digestive enzymes
what do you recommend for people just to
start
well the the first thing i i do is i
take a careful history to get a sense of
what what enzymes are likely missing
uh i'm thinking about their bile acids
is fat malabsorption part of the problem
have they had their gallbladder removed
is there a lot of bloating
uh is there uh
in their age do i have to think about uh
inadequate
acid production so i might be talking
bile
bile acids i might be talking
things to stimulate stomach acid even
as simple as apple cider vinegar and
then
we may add in enzymes for
protein digestion and carbohydrate
digestion
so pancreatic enzymes as well but
again careful history i may do
a uh a stool analysis
to understand the enzymes
so i can suggest what's going to be
appropriate for that patient
okay and and for stool analysis so i had
you know like every problem digestive
wise which i didn't even know about
until i had started dieting
um and i found that stool testing
helped but it didn't i wasn't able to
treat the problems with the information
i got from the stool tests
um i don't know if i was using the wrong
ones do you have recommendations for
how to go about finding proper testing
you want to find a practitioner who is
comfortable with doing and interpreting
uh say a complete
stool analog so you have to get the test
and you need to find a practitioner
who's comfortable uh
using that test to guide uh the
interventions
and again for uh the individual
we may have to do it in a sequential
basis it's
pretty common that for
complicated patients we will start the
evaluation
begin our interventions assess how the
person is responding
and then may add in a more
aggressive comprehensive level of
intervention
and so
it's for people who have complicated
uh more severe problems a stepwise
approach
would certainly be very common and what
are your thoughts on
how much of this has to do with
microbiome dysbiosis and
whether or not that can be addressed
well that's certainly part of it
you know as i mentioned if you have an
overgrowth
of disease promoting bacteria
that can add to the leaky gut if you
have a diet
full of emulsifiers that adds to the
leaky gut
if you have a diet full of sugar
and simple carbs that will feed the
overgrowth
of yeast and sugar-loving bacteria which
adds to the leaky gut
so the microbiome is part of it
but why did the microbiome get disrupted
it has to do with what you're feeding it
and it has to do with the medications
you're taking because your medications
are now part of the food supply
for your microbiome as along with your
all of your supplements everything you
put in your mouth
it's probably the food supply for the
microbiome
and your physical activity level
your sleep pattern your stress level
will all
also influence your microbiome
it's it's messy it's complicated
everything is interconnected
so if you're looking for a quick easy
answer
every now and then the person doesn't
have too many disturbances
and there is a quick easy answer but
most
often what i'm what i'm doing is gently
nudging
all of the uh diet and lifestyle factors
at a pace that the patient can manage
and for some people you know they're
they're willing to come in
and make really big changes very quickly
uh and others we have to make changes at
a pace that they
and their family can successfully
implement
so i think it's it's it's vitally
important
that patients experience success
with what they're doing uh so
they're not overwhelmed uh in feeling
like failures
like that that could make forward
progress
yeah one of the one of the downsides of
the carnivore diet that's
been popularized is it's very difficult
to get into it's very restrictive
and people can't a lot of people don't
stick with it because they miss
you know variety and yeah that
that's definitely an issue so the way
you go about it
you you start you get like what are the
steps in your diet the
tenets of the walls protocol
well um there's we want people to remove
the three
most uh inflammatory foods gluten dairy
eggs
and then i also identify
are they uh a
patient that i have to think about a low
lectin diet
in which case they take out all grains
all legumes all night shades
ah okay uh but for for the
introduction first thing is get rid of
the sugar get rid of gluten get rid of
dairy get rid of eggs
add more vegetables add a greater
diversity
i also want them to have uh liver once a
week
um and so that's a big cell we have to
teach them how to make liver uh
quite delicious and actually um
you know once we get them inspired uh
they often find our baked liver be one
of their
favorite meals yeah okay i'm not
surprised
liver definitely grew on me after
cleaning up my diet
yeah it you know it ends up being really
very very helpful
but again it's a conversation i have
with with the patient and their family
if all that they in a family can commit
to is
i'm going to get rid of the sugar and
the added
sugar in beverages and my foods
that's still a wonderful step
if they can say i can't do the walls
diet but i'll go in all in
on the mediterranean diet and we talk
about legumes and more vegetables
and getting rid of sugars that's a great
step
i and then you know i get them to go
a mediterranean that's gluten-free
dairy-free egg-free
and basically that's level one of the
walls diet
or people will go straight to level one
or
straight to the elimination diet
it depends on where the family is at
i and and so because you know again
because
people are successful or have immense
struggle
if they do the intervention as a family
so i really like seeing the whole family
seeing you uh
both adults reviewing the health issues
and then sorting out what they as a
family can commit to
that's smart that's smart because it is
very difficult to start removing yummy
things from your diet if you don't have
support behind you
you know it's sort of like uh and we
talked about food addiction
that if you uh think about people who
have
an issue with alcohol or
substance abuse cocaine meth
they will be struggle
but they need to be in an environment
where there is no alcohol
no math no cocaine and they may have to
adjust their friends
their social environments so their
environment can be clean
and even then it's going to be hard for
them but they will get through
withdrawal
and we have to help help them by
removing
the temptations from their environment
these addictive foods are
can have just as powerful of a craving
so if the problem food that you have
decided
you want to exclude from your diet
and it's going to be people making that
decision
i can make the case as to why they
should
but they'll be the ones who are going to
have to decide like okay i want to take
this out
i'll exclude it from my diet i'll i'm
willing to experience the discomfort of
craving
of missing that food and being hungry
for it
but i i see the value of doing that so
that's what i'm gonna do
if it's in their house now they have to
have that struggle that internal fight
continuously if they get it out of their
eating environments
they purge their house now they only
have to walk
by it in the store and
that's easy far easier than refusing
that yummy food
forever i and so
that's the big conversation i have with
folks is okay let's figure out what
you're going to exclude
what you're ready to remove and now you
want to go home and get it out of your
eating environment
because if you have it in your eating
environment you will be exhausted
by resistance and it will find your
mouth and you'll chew
and you'll feel like a failure uh just
like
uh if you really want to quit your
alcohol
you're going to get it out of your edn
living environment
uh it's a uh we're very upfront with
that conversation
if people are we'll have that
conversation we'll go through that
effort to take
the foods that they have now and the
patient has to say
this is what i want to remove that
person will be successful
but the person who says well honey you
might remove it but i'm going to keep
eating that because i love it
and that person is going to have a huge
struggle
and those folks i basically sent family
counseling
to work through how they can have a
mutually
agreeable resolution to that problem
because we need to find a way that
that will work for that family that
honors the needs of uh both adults and
everyone in the family
ignore it you have to ignore that
conflict
the person will struggle uh they will
fail but if you send them to
you know we have some uh talk therapists
that are really very skilled at helping
families
come to a more satisfactory resolution
of how to address those food addictions
in ways that work for the family and
those those therapists are well versed
in the diet right so you're not going to
go to a therapist and they're going to
go well that's crazy in the first place
don't
don't do that yes we um
we prefer to find people who uh aren't
are comfortable with food addictions
uh in dealing with food addictions yeah
okay so um for your you know i should
say and to that end you know we do have
um uh certified walls uh practitioners
uh and we are working on getting more uh
mental health
uh practitioners in that lineup yeah
well that's good
that's important for these kind of
things i had um one
so i started off i wasn't doing any diet
i was doing diet research but i hadn't
heard of the kind of alternative diet
scene that i'm now
well aware of and i found the one of my
worst foods was
soy for neurological problems so i
didn't just have arthritis i had a whole
host of them but for
like psychiatric issues soy was just
a complete disaster so you said you you
find people
some people are okay with legumes yeah
some people
you know i would keep in mind that
humans are incredibly resilient our
ancestors migrated out of africa across
the globe
into many many different ecosystems
and so humans have had reproductive
success we thrive
with a wide variety of dietary patterns
when we've adapted westernized diets and
created these leaky guts
then we develop these food sensitivities
to proteins
and develop chronic diseases
it's not universal when we have a
healthy gut
and our digestion is intact in fact
we can eat a wide variety of proteins
plants
literally thousands of different plants
hundreds of different animal species in
the disease state
there may be a wide variety of food
proteins to which
you've you've developed a sensitivity
there that are going to have to be
addressed
but so so it's two different things
we we historically have been able to eat
a
huge wide variety of foods
once we developed processed foods with
all of these
emulsifiers food additives and we
are taking these medications alcohol
stress and develop the leaky gut
and food sensitivities then yes we can
also develop a wide variety of
food intolerances as well uh an example
of an emulsifier that'd be like soy
lecithin right which is in everything
so correct
so uh
soy lecithin there there are a wide
variety
of emulsifiers that are used to keep
fats
suspended so you can think about
even a lot of the boxed milks uh
soy milk nut milks will have emulsifiers
in them
uh dressings will have emulsifiers in
them sauces will have emulsifiers in
them
and all these compounds that keep
food products in suspension
liquefied together when they're in our
gut
we'll also uh liquefy
the the mucin layer that protects the
lining
of the small ball beautiful it makes it
much more
likely that we will develop that leaky
gut
so you know if you're eating food that's
in a box in a jar
with a label it probably has emulsifiers
and food
additives that are not so good for your
health
if you're eating things that don't have
a bar
code on it but are ingredients you know
like
apples pears uh
parsley cilantro romaine lettuce
kale chard beets carrots
your variety of meats
um those those will not have food
additives in them
and those will be good for you more
likely you that you'll be more likely
to tolerate those and thrive eating
but but that means you have to learn how
to cook you have to learn how to
menu plan you have to learn how to shop
uh
and sadly so many
americans and people all over the globe
we've been so squeezed for time
so pressed for time that we have
outsourced our our food preparation
uh and we're eating fast food we're
eating food that has already been cooked
or
processed and we don't know how to cook
anymore
we don't know how to shop we don't know
how to meal plan we don't know how to
uh deal with leftovers i
and so it's very often we also have to
help people
acquire all of those skills when i first
started i was
23 and i was living with roommates so
all the tempting foods were around
and everything i ate tasted terrible
because i'd been eating out for
at least four years basically all my
meals and then i was making stews
and i wasn't on the carnivore diet i was
doing you know sweet potatoes and
parsnips and greens and some
apples and and meat but i couldn't get i
was so used to the processed food
taste and like chinese food japanese
food that
i had no appetite for whole foods
which was is also how long it would take
you how long did it take you to
uh adjust your palate
probably um
probably six weeks
minimum more like three months and then
i still for a number of years kept
trying to reintroduce foods that i used
to like like i tried to reintroduce
dairy a number of times unsuccessfully
i tried soy i tried different grains
and just got walloped each time it
wasn't actually until i became
very limited on the diet i am now that
all my cravings went away
but i would say probably three months
yeah yeah without you you know
it was really quite remarkable i
i spent three months researching
figuring out how to
take all those key nutrients identified
from my research
and translate them into the paleo diet
started that new way of eating december
26
and i immediately that
that was the food that i craved wow so
i had this immense craving for greens i
had
huge huge amounts of greens uh you know
uh garlic uh uh huge craving for garlic
as well
uh and uh yeah liver
uh i got into liver and i got that going
i did not really i don't
i can't recall missing the other stuff
because
this eating what was so delicious
to me and
you know when my pain was gone for the
first time yeah
that was that was like uh you know
they tried general neurology
uh in 2007 you know was more frequent
more severe
far more difficult to turn off i was
deeply afraid that it was going to turn
permanently on
in which case light sound touch
speaking swallowing all that triggered
you know
you know intense electrical pain um with
accompanied by grimacing
uh and at that point i'd come to terms
with
i was likely going to be demented by my
illness i was likely going to end up
bedridden by my illness i and
i was deeply afraid it's going to end up
with this intractable pain
so to be pain free for the first time in
27 years
27 years jesus i am
yes i watch my kids growing up and they
have a variety of challenges that they
hit you know they feel like you know
their failures or or you know
beating themselves up i remind them like
you know
keep in mind i uh screwed up for 27
years
immense amount of suffering that i had
to endure before i finally
learned the lesson i needed to learn so
and i try to tell my patients and my
followers that
we're all screwing up we we all make
mistakes we all
uh experience uh big setbacks uh
in our health in our work life in our
family life
and if you can take the moment of when
i've had that set
back and think what is it that i need to
learn
what can i learn what could i learn from
this setback
then um that can change everything
yeah and then you can begin to see you
can begin to observe you can begin to
see like
well that food when i ate that
then my joints were worse then my face
pain turned on
hell i'm not gonna eat that anymore
once you begin to get curious like what
can i learn what patterns
can i pay attention to then people
can you know like yourself and like
myself
we begin to get these aha and then
another aha
and you steadily refine what
what it is that your body requires needs
and that will probably change over time
as your microbiome heals as your
intestines heal and you don't have a
leaky gut
as your stomach heals and you can now
make stomach acid again
as your pancreas heals and you can now
make your pancreatic
enzymes again you may find
that what you can eat becomes more
expensive
but that may take several years
okay okay i was going to get into that
um i've been there
on this diet so it's just it was
originally just ruminant meat and i was
on that for two years
and i actually have become less
sensitive i can drink tea now i used to
not be able to drink tea i can eat
chicken
um so i am healing are there
and there there are a lot of people who
end up on this carnivore diet especially
the meat only version who are completely
screwed up
um gut wise are there things that
people on this diet are missing by just
waiting
so on the carnivore diet some of the uh
concerns that i have uh one vitamin c
uh vitamin c
is generally a plant nutrient
uh and a lot of the carnivore diet folks
as i look at what they're eating are
likely insufficient in vitamin c
the other concern i have is
they may be too heavy on liver
liver great super food i love it i have
it once a week
uh and it is one of our family favorite
meals particularly the baked liver
like so delicious i'm salivating
thinking about i've never had
anything about liver uh it's just
amazing
uh it is a a great source again of yeast
absorbed minerals
vitamins very high in vitamin a
pre-made vitamin a retinol retinol
is a nutrient that has a let's see a
narrow
um ideal range of intake
if you're too low your immune cells
don't work very well
and you're much higher risk of
infections including the coronavirus
influenza virus much higher risk of
cancers
and probably also a higher risk of
autoimmunity issues like you and i would
have had
if you are too high in vitamin a
then you are at risk of scarring or
fibrosis
in the lungs in the heart
and in the liver and so
my preference is to have people eat
liver once a week
and a wide variety of colorful plants
so that you have you know a sufficient
vitamin a
but we're not getting too much vitamin a
to get in that toxic range
because once you have vitamin a in the
toxic range
we don't because it's fat soluble we
don't have a way of getting it out
and this can be a reason that people end
up with liver failure
lung failure and can be really quite
catastrophic
in autopsy studies uh about a
um folks had evidence of vitamin a
insufficiency so that's actually quite
common
um and i think it's about
twenty percent had evidence of vitamin a
toxicity
so that also it's fairly common
and uh i've been on podcasts with other
carnivore diets who were advocating a
pound of liver a week and i'm like well
that's going to
certainly put people at risk
chronic in a information
and that can take to
reveal itself 10 years and by that time
uh you're completely screwed because
there is no way to remove the excess
vitamin a
and you've already created huge damage
to your liver
to your heart into your lungs so
those are the two nutrients i really
worry about vitamin c
not enough vitamin a depending on
on the frequency that you eat in liver
potentially
too much interesting okay
i know that there are a lot of people
who are very into
the supplements the like oral capsules
of liver and i found
if i just eat liver as often as i crave
it i don't really
have to worry about overconsumption
because i get sick of it but
perhaps if you're taking capsules and
just swallowing it well if you're eating
liver as often as you want and you're
having it more than once a week you're
probably having too much vitamin a
and is there a difference between so
where do you get vitamin a other than
liver are there plant sources for
vitamin a or no
so in terms of pre-made vitamin a
that is uh liver uh you probably also
would get some from a
kidney as well uh much smaller amount
from uh
other meats but liver is the main driver
and again super so super food
i like it a lot i encourage my tribe to
have it
i want people to have uh liver once a
week
i don't want to have more than once a
week
i and my preference is like six to eight
ounces
six if you're female eight if you're
male
you know if you're really petite and i
do have some very petite
folks you know then i might reduce the
amount
a little further interesting
um i've had pretty extensive vitamin
testing because i started the carnivore
diet when i was breastfeeding and i was
very concerned about my kid
right i was like i went from meat and
greens
oh you know what happened when i did
clean up my diet i did really like salad
like i'm a huge greens fan
but then with the pregnancy i also took
another round of antibiotics right
before the pregnancy and i don't know if
that's what
removed my tolerance but then i couldn't
tolerate any i couldn't even tolerate
lettuce i was just eating
i i stopped the kale so um
the antibiotics would certainly change
your microbiome and that
likely contributed to that yeah change
absolutely so somebody like me like i've
tried a number of times to introduce
like
cooked peeled small quantities of plants
and i end up with arthritis in a couple
of weeks um
is there something i'm missing to in to
heal myself
back to a more varied diet rather than
just waiting
so if you were in my clinical practice i
would probably do a digestive uh
complete digestive assessment
to look at your enzymes and see do we
need to add
enzymes back should we add more
uh probiotics back should we start with
a small amount of something like
sauerkraut juice
and see if that is tolerated uh
again small
uh uh and make that those changes uh
gradually
but i'd probably start with an
assessment of
uh do you have a leaky gut and what's
going on with your digestive enzymes
so we have to fix the leaky gut and
address the digestive enzymes
once those are correct have been
corrected
then i would start with a small amount
of
fermented uh food
and i would use something like
sauerkraut juice
or kimchi juice another thing that might
work
to start would be apple cider vinegar
and you could try i can tolerate that
now yeah
uh and so firesider would be
a the next thing to try after that fire
cider
what is that um the the source is apple
cider vinegar that's been fermented with
burdock root
uh ginger uh garlic
uh and i believe uh uh uh
peppers uh so it's got some bite to it
it's fiery it's tasty it's very tasty so
i put a tablespoon of that
and a um you know eight four ounce glass
of water and i'll drink that
uh you know all winter long uh twice a
day as part of my
self-care routine to reduce my risk of
a viral infection during the winter
so i'd start with apple cider vinegar
i'd go to fire cider
and see if that's taller yeah and again
we're talking like a tablespoon
yeah uh twice a day if that if that goes
well
then i would add sauerkraut juice
not the sauerkraut itself sauerkraut
juice again tablespoon a day
that goes well i might add beet kabash
tablespoon a day and then increase
the fermented you know sauerkraut juice
beet kvass
that's going well if that's going well
now i might try a fork full of
sauerkraut
wow that's actual sauerkraut
nerve-wracking so
you know taking your time and if we if
we go with
the fermented foods first they've
already been uh
we're repopulating your microbiome with
a healthier mix
so you're more likely to have maintain
um a
[Music]
healthy cell wall so it's less likely to
be leaky gut
you'll get some more digestive enzymes
along with the bacteria
and then i think you're more likely to
be successful
emphasis small and gradual
emphasis on understanding have we fixed
the leaky gut
and have we addressed any
digestive enzyme issues
and generally that's been quite
successful so uh
that would be a strategy that i would
suggest for that sounds reasonable like
yourself
yeah yeah that does sound reasonable um
one of the things i've noticed
also in the carnivore community so i
switched over the diet and i did manage
to get my autoimmune and my neurological
and plethora of other problems under
control but i didn't address the leaky
gut and the carnivore diet didn't
fix it i had a really severe c difficile
infection
from years of antibiotic use and it
wasn't until i
fixed that about a year into the
carnivore diet
that i started to become more tolerant
to things
yeah so when c diff is a problem
uh it's a couple of things that i think
about
that is the one indication for fecal
transplants that have been very
successful yeah yeah i did those
two another uh very interesting study
that looked at um
using fecal material frozen and capsules
and they took uh 30 30 capsules that's
what i did that's how i got rid of it
30 capsules of poop
so here's another strategy that you can
also use
30 capsules of
a bacillus producing
micro probiotic bsl
number three is another great example
uh so in my clinical practice when
individuals have had
c diff that's a strategy that i'll use
is
escalating doses of a soil-based
probiotic
or escalating doses of vsl number three
to see if we can get resolve the
diarrhea that way
and of course fecal transplant is an
improved indication for
a refractory c diff
that worked i i tried i tried that
initially and uh
it wasn't successful at all and i think
it's because my
problem was almost entirely in my small
intestine
so it just didn't hit that area but i
didn't
i did the oral stuff and it fixed it and
like i could feel my symptoms resolved
the next day
it was insane it can be very helpful
absolutely
so last question for you uh how is your
ms now do you have any lingering
symptoms
so i uh bike i can bike for hours i can
uh
hike um i'm pain-free
if however uh i came to your house
and you accidentally served me eggs
when six to 12 hours my face pain would
turn on
same thing with dairy or gluten so for
me
those foods continue to be triggers and
so
i'm very careful about all of that uh
and i also noticed that when
we used to fly to places to do events
uh and if i did more than six hours of
flight times in a month
that would that would be those toxins
would be stressful enough that that
that might trigger a face paint so as
long as i'm on my self-care routines i
continue to get
stronger my last visit to my neurologist
i was doing push-ups vertical leaps
standing on one foot
eyes closed eyes open he's like okay
terry
you are amazing um and
you know if we do an mri i still have
the lesions in my spinal cord that
are visible and my neurologist
his point is those are old lesions those
are old scars
of course that they're going to stay but
your brain
you've clearly rewired your brain and
your spinal cord
uh and so in terms of function
i'm you know i'm certainly in better
shape than most 65 year old women
uh that is jim that is
absolutely fantastic uh thank you
thank you so much for coming on where
can people go to find you
so terrywalls.com
t-e-r-r-y-wallswahls.com
and if you'd like to get a single page
handout
of our diet you can put in a
refrigerator
forward slash terrywalls.comforwardslash
that'll get you started
great thank you very much for coming on
you're welcome
and good luck uh those small incremental
steps would likely be
quite transformative for you i'm gonna
do it i'm gonna do it i can do apple
cider vinegar i couldn't
for three years and i can do it now so
right so i'm gonna take your advice if
you're making you're making progress
just be patient uh very patient let us
know how it goes
okay i will i'll keep you posted thank
you you're very welcome good luck to you
now
thanks bye bye
you